Well,
I don't know that every manager in the
world who's a Buddhist is necessarily a
good manager.
On the other hand,
there are certain elements of Buddhism I
think are very positive for management,
especially now such as let go of the
past and if you look at coaches,
there was a study done on coaches and
Buddha believed that anyone can change.
You know what the study showed?
Coaches who believe people can change
are much more effective than those who
do not believe.
People can change the well.
Amazingly.
Some people don't believe other people
can change other pretty useless as
coaches.
So I.
my Buddhist philosophy is a simple one.
It basically involves let go of the past
except what is move forward.
Make the best of what you have.
Be Happy and content.